foreign
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we're here with malabama hi
everybody well we also got the rest of
our team here and seems that we're
missing someone don't worry he's not
late he's just not going to be here
today TK Coleman is in Detroit this week
he's speaking at several schools helping
some kids understand what it means to
live a meaningful life with less he'll
be back on the episode next week but
don't worry we have a special guest
today you'll be introduced to her in a
moment coming up today on this free
public minimal episode we're talking to
a listener about dealing with a
disrespectful family member we also have
an outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question and a listener tip
for you you can check out the full two
hour maximal edition of episode 377
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into several simple
living segments you can check that out
at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all advertisements suck
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or comment for our show give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcasts that the minimalists.com our
first question today is from Joy
my 70 year old mother is living with me
she's on Social Security and only gets
by with help of my father her ex-husband
reluctantly and me she's been mentally
abusive since I can remember but she is
totally oblivious to it
she's quite Delirious in many areas
and I say that with some respect I told
her my only rule for living in my house
was going to therapy a decision I
started questioning asking after knowing
what I do about changing People
acceptance expectations I've still done
everything begged countless times
thinking if I show how painful this is
for me she would go
if she doesn't live in my house she's
homeless her living here is causing me
such mental agony
as living together was always extremely
toxic and I feel incredibly stuck
she's living in my daughter's room while
my daughter is cramped in mine
I consider her a level one hoarder and
has a major shopping addiction she
doesn't respect any of my rules around
bringing things into my house my house
is now cluttered
lately I felt that maybe I should put
focus on grieving her even though she's
10 feet away from me our relationship is
completely done and I've asked her to
not speak to me as much as possible
until she has gotten some help making
this feel similar to a death that it was
a boundary I felt necessary knowing I
cannot change or Force someone to get
help if they don't want to but being
forced to live to go or live together
where do I go from here
joining us in the studio today to help
us answer this question and several
other questions as well as Lori Gottlieb
she's not only a therapist but she's the
author of this new book although it's a
journal really it's called maybe you
should talk to someone the journal as
you can see I have a whole lot of tabs
here Lori we're going to be diving deep
in to this book today ladies and
gentlemen Lori Gottlieb yeah
now it's a warm introduction but for a
very serious question yes Joy's question
she has a mother who she perceives to be
disrespectful to not be attentive to her
needs to her desires
to the family Dynamic that we have going
on here and I think it's probably
important to highlight I'm really
interested in in your point of view here
that every relationship has some sort of
cost of admission right because I'm not
going to be in a relationship a business
relationship friendship with Ryan if
he's constantly disrespectful to me or
if he doesn't appreciate my own desires
my own wants my own needs out of life
but I wanted to start with a chapter
from your not a chapter a selection from
your book here this is on page 76 and
you have a quote here our relationships
can't change until we have something new
to bring to them yeah now Ryan's been
using the journal as well yeah and maybe
you could talk about that in a little
bit here but I thought that was a great
quote to start to address Joy's
conundrum that she's having with her
mother yeah that's that's exactly where
I was gonna go which is that I think
that she's expecting that she's going to
have some kind of relationship with her
mother that she's wanted for a very long
time and that if she sets boundaries and
then her mother gets help that something
will change with the mother but
nothing's really going to change with
the mother because she's not changing
and so she needs to first of all
understand what her mother's limitations
are and I think that the when she said
she's grieving already like as if she's
dead I think what she's grieving is the
relationship that she wanted to have
with her mother that she's probably not
going to have that is not who her mother
is so that's where the grieving comes in
and that's where the fight is that she's
having she's having this fight like I
need you to be this person I'm being
very reasonable why can't you be
reasonable right
um and so I think she needs to kind of
change what her
um the dance that she's doing with her
mother you know we all do these this
dance with somebody else right and so if
you change your dance steps the other
person either has to change their dance
steps or they're just going to fall flat
on the floor so she needs to change her
dance steps which is obviously her
mother has not responded well to hey you
need to get help her mother doesn't seem
interested in that
um you know she's telling her mother
don't talk to me as much as possible
which doesn't seem like a very tenable
situation so I think it's more about
grieving that her mother is not the
person and she's not going to have the
relationship that she wanted but could
she have a different relationship where
she doesn't have those kinds of
expectations and what will happen if she
changes and then maybe the mother
doesn't feel so criticized disliked
um you know unwelcome what might happen
there hmm man I got a lot of empathy for
Joy I um I and I'm not the only one
who's got you know Mom and Dad issues I
mean I think everyone's got him to a
certain extent um
yeah I mean for me uh and my mother
specifically so I'm trying to I'm trying
to like talk about uh Joy's question
here in an observational way rather than
like prescribing Joy something here but
so that's what I'll do I'll talk about
my my relationship with my mom
um I wanted our relationship to be a
certain way
and I wanted that ever since I was a kid
um it did not go that way
um in fact it went
probably the completely opposite
direction of where I wish you know a
mother-son relationship would be so what
I did when I got older and um you know
got my own job got out of the house is I
pretty much stopped talking to her
and
um you know she would call me up and hey
why don't you talk to me and you know
you don't call me enough and I'm like
Mom like I love you but you know here
are the issues that I have and um I I
don't I don't owe you anything you know
like I don't know what else to say that
was not the best approach because it
didn't
Foster anything between my mom and I and
I'll tell you the last like six or seven
years I've been working really hard to
have a good relationship with her and
where it started
um was I had this kind of Revelation
about
I don't know I was having like a pity
party party for myself like oh you know
Mom doesn't understand me she doesn't
get my struggles you know and he's very
emo yes very Emo's listening to us some
Fallout Boy and
and but then it hit me I'm like well
wait a minute
um you know I want my mom to understand
my battles
and my mom has her own battles that I
refuse to try and understand
um and it hit me where I was like oh if
I want this relationship to go anywhere
I have to be the one who shows to my mom
that I at least understand where she's
coming from and then that will hopefully
open up a possibility for her to kind of
you know see where I'm coming from and I
called her up one day and I said hey Mom
I just want to let you know um
I was sitting around thinking and um I
had this huge Epiphany that I've never
really showed you how I understand that
you have a lot going on and I really
want to not just understand your battles
but I want to respect your battles
and in order for uh for me to do that um
you know we need to figure out uh what
you know what you need what I need so
let's talk about that and I hey what do
you need and she kind of just asked me
you know call her once a week and um a
couple other things and I'm like great I
would do that for you absolutely mom and
I'll tell you when I did that she
started to
um see my battles and started to respect
my battles a little bit more and we
still you know get into it sometimes but
you know like Josh said every
relationship is going to have some type
of cost but I'll tell you like when I
when I approach it in that way of
looking at my mom uh because because I
do love her and to love someone is to
you know see them for who they are
without wanting to change them and and
that's the approach that I've taken with
my mom and um man like going out of my
way to show her that not only do I
respect your battles but I I hear what
her problems are and
um just be a good list Center like that
has completely changed our relationship
you know one more thing I'll say too
that was really hard for me to accept
was you know we all think parents should
be a certain way yeah you know
um I don't I don't know why uh this is
but you know I expected my mom and dad
to know everything they had me my dad
was 22 my mom was 20.
and I am 41 years old right now I don't
have a lot figured out
so I don't know why my younger self
would expect my mother and my father to
have it figured out at 20 and 22.
um and then what that kind of led me to
was
I have to be the parent to my parent and
that is such a difficult thing I I would
say more you have to be the teacher to
your parents because I think that we
don't want to have to parent our parents
um you know when we're young we call
that the parentified child which is you
know your parents haven't sort of grown
up and you're the child who kind of sees
what needs to happen and you take all
these on all this sort of adult
responsibility and that's that's really
problematic when we get older and we're
adults and we feel like okay I don't
rely on my parents in the same way but
emotionally we still want our parents to
be our parents
and so I think that if you think about
it as being the teacher that that my
parents I'm talking for you now we're 20
and 22 when they had me and they didn't
know a lot and I have the benefit of
having done work on myself I have the
benefit of having learned a lot of
things and I actually can teach them
things that will not only help them but
will help our relationship you know I
have a podcast called the dear therapist
podcast and we had someone come on and
he was saying you know I I'm having this
child and my my parents didn't know how
to sort of be parents to me and I don't
want them to do that around the
grandchild and I want to be a good dad
and we really help this person to see
like you have some things to be you have
knowledge to be a teacher to your
parents and it really changed the
relationship especially with his dad the
mom was a little less open to it at
first but then she came around the dad
was very receptive to it
so I think if we if we think about it
that way also the other thing you
mentioned that comes to mind is a lot of
times like when I see couples for
example it's always about like you go
first you need to change first and we do
that with our parents like you need to
change Mom and Dad right before I will
change you want me to call once a week
okay but you got to do this stuff for me
like you've got to be the parent and I
think that what we see is it's not about
who goes first it's about somebody again
needs to change their dance steps but
you need to change your dance steps
first they will change their dance steps
might not be right away it might not be
in exactly the way you want but
eventually you will start to see some
movement on the other side oh yeah I
love that context of being a teacher
that is so much more powerful than
thinking about yeah me having to be uh
my mom's parent but you know it's
interesting because what she needed from
me I needed from her and I totally was
in the space of like well she's my mom
so she's gonna have to be the one who
gives in first and then it becomes
transactional yes yeah which isn't love
at all and I know that's not what Joy is
going for here what Joy is trying to
understand is how do I make this Dynamic
work because we're dancing to completely
different dances right now and we want
to be careful not to moralize into this
either yes your mom might be a level one
horse I was a level two or level three
hoarder if you look at the whole we did
a whole podcast episode about hoarding
and the five different stages of
hoarding that's not a morally bad thing
it's a problem for her and it's
especially a problem for you if the
stuff is getting in the way and so when
I talk about the cost of admission for a
relationship we know right now that if
your mom was coming to your house and
beating your walls with a sledgehammer
you would say Hey you have to get out of
my house this is unacceptable the cost
of the admission is you can't beat my
walls down with a sledgehammer right but
now you have to understand what is your
non-negotiable or your series of your
list of non-negotiables here are the
things that can't happen if you want to
live under this roof with me and if you
understand that I wouldn't I wouldn't
get too pedantic and make the list of
150 items that can't possibly be
followed but what does respect look like
to you because my guess is your mom
doesn't even understand the ways in
which you perceive your being
disrespected that's right that's right I
mean you know she doesn't realize that
you know when you're a hoarder you don't
really realize that other people might
not might not feel the same way about
this that's right
um and I and I think the other thing is
too when somebody doesn't realize they
have a problem and you keep telling them
to go to therapy she's kind of like I
don't understand what the problem is
right so so there's that going on and I
think the the other thing I was thinking
about when I was listening to her
voicemail was this idea that she said
you know if I don't take her in she will
be homeless and I really wonder about
that when people come into therapy and
they say you know like I'm trapped in
this way often they're not actually
trapped there might be a less than ideal
you know solution to this
um but it doesn't mean that the only
solution is that her mother has to live
with her you know it reminds me of and
maybe you should talk to someone in the
book that led to the journal there's
this scene where I'm with my therapist
and he said you know you remind me of
this prisoner it's a cartoon it's a
cartoon you remember this cartoon and
it's a prisoner shaking the bars
desperately trying to get out but on the
right and the left it's open
bars you can walk around so many of us
feel like that we're like shaking the
bars I'm trapped I'm trapped I'm trapped
even though it's open on the right and
the left so what keeps us from walking
around the bars and in Joy's case I
don't know her but it might be that
she's really hoping that she can have a
different relationship with her mom that
she's not even aware of this right you
know in her mind she's like no no no
that's not what I want I don't want her
to live with me and all that but maybe
there's a part of her and maybe the
younger part of her that feels like
maybe something different could happen
here yeah I was in a similar predicament
when I was 19 my mom had real bad
alcohol problem and I started working
more so I could pay my mom's rent
because I wasn't going to be living with
Mom and so for me it meant now I'm not
suggesting this to Joy necessarily but
it it was empowering to know that the
story I was telling myself oh my mom's
going to be homeless if she doesn't live
with me well okay maybe that's true but
maybe there's an alternative solution as
well one other thing I'd like to say is
I want to get really clear on the well
you say she's emotionally abusive okay
but you can say that to her she may have
no idea what that even means I want to
get specific what is that emotional
abuse look like I really don't like when
you say this I really don't like when
you talk to me this way when you raise
your voice in these scenarios it makes
me feel unheard
right and and also the thing about
boundaries that a lot of people don't
understand is they feel like I'm setting
a boundary and if the other person
doesn't do the thing that I request then
the boundary has been broken the
boundary is something we hold with
ourselves
so what I mean by that is if you say to
someone you know
um I don't like it when you yell at me
that really upsets me please don't yell
at me anymore that's not really a
boundary a boundary is
part you say I don't like it when you
yell at me this is what happens for me
when you yell at me it really scares me
I I don't like it it's disrespectful and
if you yell at me I am going to end the
phone call leave the room you know
whatever you're going to do and then the
boundaries with yourself are you going
to do the thing you said you were going
to do and so many times we say oh they
didn't they didn't respect my boundary
and then I'm helpless you're not
helpless you have a plan for what you're
going to do if someone doesn't respond
to your request a boundary is a request
and then it's it's the limit that you
set with yourself I will do this maybe
for her it's if my mom continues to act
in this way even though I've requested
um I'm going to figure out a way for her
to live somewhere else yes yeah and the
boundaries I found in my own life yes
people will trample your boundaries if
you let them but I was often the one
trampling my own boundaries and so when
we set a boundary we set it for a reason
and it may be difficult to stick to it
because recognizing there are
consequences if someone's not willing to
pay the cost of admission for being in
this relationship with me then I need to
hold up my end of the bargain getting a
cue from Professor Sean over here if you
hear a little ding in your ear it's
because uh he's telling us to wrap up in
a meaningful way uh Joy I want to send
you a copy of the journal maybe you
should talk to someone and we're going
to be going through this on the rest of
the podcast as well I think you'll find
immense value in this book in this
journal and we'll talk more about it
here in a second Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock that's right
you can follow the minimals on Tick Tock
also Facebook Instagram and Twitter at
the minimalist now during the lightning
round we each have 60 seconds to answer
your questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maximums and
the show notes over it the
minimalists.com podcast so you can copy
and share our pithy answers if you like
Ryan we'll start with you we got a
question from zzz test
because I keep to myself others
misinterpret that as me being mysterious
and want to pry how do I keep other
people out of my business all right
Professor Sean give me 60 Seconds
here is my pithy answer
fulfilling other people's expectations
is not fulfilling so here's the thing I
have expectations of Josh as a business
partner I've got expectations as
malabama as as as one of our employees
I've got expectations of my wife I've
got expectations of my parents but what
I realize is that the more expectations
I have for others the less they get met
and I I'm flipping that uh for you zzz
test
um other people's expectations of you
doesn't mean that you have to live up to
them you can respect them you can try to
understand them you can uh you know be
loving and kind without living up to
everyone else's expectations because
living up to everyone else's
expectations is a great recipe for
disaster yeah I would just Echo what
you're saying there it's a great way to
be unsatisfied to be unfulfilled by
trying to fulfill everyone else yes what
a great Point give me 60 seconds John so
here's something Petty for you
it's an older but a goodie you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you so no one
in my life tries into my business triple
Z no one in my life is constantly trying
to figure out what's going on with me
personally because I wouldn't tolerate
that kind of behavior I can't change the
people if Ryan all of a sudden wanted to
be a nosy Nancy and was constantly
asking me hey what's going on with us
what's going on with this and gossiping
the key wouldn't be to make him gossip
less it would be to surround myself with
people who don't treat me that way and I
think that is the key here for triple Z
it's about letting go of needing the
friendships you have right now and
moving toward the more empowering
relationships that aren't going to pry
into your business so I saw a meme the
other day it was uh was a picture of a
um like a Sandwich Board sign on I think
it was on the outside of a bar or a
restaurant I swear to God I think I sent
you a picture of it it said um you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you and then it
just put a known
like we know exactly who said that
see I've inspired my whole life to be
unknown so this is uh this is perfect
yeah oh it's so funny I'm like I know
exactly who said that come on it's my
new moniker if you Google it it comes up
pretty easily anyway yeah do these
people not have Google I guess not it's
all good uh Right Here Right Now by the
way we'll check in with the live stream
here in a second but first real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing going on in the life of the
minimalists we are beginning to speak
Ryan and I will go out to universities
to corporations to conferences one a
month generally we'll go out and we'll
talk to your organization if you'd like
to hire the minimalists to speak you can
reach out to our agent you can find
actually our speaking demo is over there
as well as well at the minimalists.com
speaking we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well you can reach out to
us we'd be happy to have you hire us to
come out and speak to your conference
your organization your group the
minimalists.com
speaking for more details malabama let's
check in with the patreon live stream
what do you got for us we have a
question here from Brit she says I'm
constantly cleaning up behind my
two-year-old and trying to keep the home
tidy we live very minimally but I feel
like my OCD is getting in the way of me
being present as a parent any tips on
finding a balance I don't think you want
to find balance it's weird because we
don't ever want to find balance in any
other area of our life really right
we're not looking for balance we're
looking for contentment because you can
balance all of the wrong things the
things that are inappropriate for your
life and yes you could have a bunch of
things that are in Balance but not
achieve what you're actually trying to
achieve what you're trying to achieve
here is Brit you want to be present with
your two-year-old right and yet you're
clinging to the idea of the way things
should be when a two-year-old isn't
present and I know this from first-hand
experience Ella when she was two I think
she was trying out for the Taliban
so she terrorized our house she was too
much of a terror for them actually yes
they rejected her like she's a little
over the top
and so when I realized Brit is I had to
not forcibly let go because letting go
is not something you do I had to loosen
my grip hey yes I might prefer things to
be this way
but what is the worst thing that could
happen if it's not this way I was on our
back patio yesterday and there were
several little toys strewn across the
the patio
and yes my OCD was like Hey it shouldn't
be this way but what's the worst thing
that could happen I might step on one
but even then I see them so I'm not
going to step on one and so I recognize
that my expectation I had the hope that
I had oh I hope things are going to be
this way actually got in the way of what
me being present with my daughter and as
soon as I let go of that hope or that
expectation and just accepted reality
for what it was and I can't prescribe
that to you I can't say just accept
things for how they are good luck with
that but if you see things for how they
are you'll recognize the way you want
the world to be is different from the
way the world is and that is why you're
experiencing the discontent there's no
other reason
Brit I totally understand the essence of
your questionnaire like when do you just
give up on cleaning up after your
two-year-old and and uh kind of let
things be the way that they are and Josh
is right like there's no magic bullet
answer here to let you uh to make you
let go of those expectations that you
have but what I'll say is this is a
two-year-old they're messy
they're really really messy and yeah
you've got to clean up after them
um the answer isn't says just stop
cleaning up after them uh but but you
know what I'll say is it will get easier
as time goes on and then you could show
them how to help you show them how to uh
raise the standards for themselves but
yeah this is a temporary time it's gonna
get better for you Brett yes indeed
we'll check back in with the live stream
here in a little bit but first maliban
what do you got for us here's a
minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hi my name is Lisa Benson and I'm
calling from wall fan match I've been
thinking a lot about souvenirs when you
go on a trip lately or recently our 10
year old niece came out to visit us and
she bought something small for every
family member to show that she was
thinking of them when she was visiting
and traveling but I'm thinking of a
different way that you could show that
to a friend or family member without
having to buy them something which is
they give you something small to take
with you maybe it's a drawing or a
treasured object or whatever and you
take a picture of that that object at
some landmark or a special place a
moment and you share that photo with
them so it's like a piece of them was
with you on the trip that is our minimal
episode for today we'll see on patreon
for the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 377 which includes a million
more questions from our listeners and
Lori tackle some of those questions with
us a private minimalist home home tour a
special photo from Danny unknown we've
got our Infamous obsolete objects and
impulse purchases segments we have
several new rules for decluttering we
have an outstanding added value segment
for you Ryan it is the vibiest song I've
heard in a long time
we also have uh much much more
of less if you'll hear all that check
out the minimalist private podcast
episode this week at patreon.com the
minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to all of
our archives all the way back to episode
zero zero one yes indeed big thanks to
Lori Gottlieb you can check out maybe
you should talk to someone the journal
will also put a link to her podcast in
the show notes as well you can find
those at developmentalists.com
podcast alright y'all if you leave here
today with just one message
but it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for being here we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign